- The only two things you have,
the only thing you have to think about
when building a business
around your passion,
is what do you need, not
what you're hoping for.
Because if you figure
out what you need ...
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(energetic pop music)
("Suncats" by Hazlett)
I'm probably following
the tracks of my life.
I'm probably right now,
disproportionately my mom,
and sooner than later
I'll be more like my dad,
much like what I went through,
which is the first 14 years
of my life was only mom,
and then the next, you know, kind of,
15 years of my life was heavily dad.
(Suncats by "Hazlett")
My dad did things for me that actually
allowed me to be the enigma that I am
for somebody who is such a self-promoter,
gift of gab, sizzle got.
I'm convinced.
Which is tough to say out loud,
that the things I most despise,
and people with charisma, I actually am.
And that the parenting is what did it.
That I was willing to lie to sell.
And that would have
manifested as me with girls,
and that would have
manifested me with product,
and I know this 'cause I did it.
'Cause at 14 and 15 I lied to sell wine.
I just did.
And so, the fact that I got lucky
and came into a father
who looks at embellishment
as a cardinal one strike you're -
if you embellish to my dad,
if DRock called my dad and said right now,
Sasha you'll never believe this,
80 thousand people just watched that clip,
and the actual amount of people
that watched that clip was 78 thousand,
my dad would never trust DRock again.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
So think about, I'm being serious.
Think about what I'm talking about.
Yes.
We're talking about extremity
around (spit noise).
So I went from gift of gab, fucking,
what some people think I am
when they first see one minute video,
to being suffocated.
- I was gonna say that word, suffocated,
did you feel suffocated?
- In a great way.
At the time it was fear.
I was fearful to embellish
or lie to my dad.
So it just started getting
me into practice to not.
Which ironically had a
counter-cultural move too,
it made me not to everybody else,
but made me to him
ironically at times as well,
'cause I didn't want to
deal with the ramifications
of delusional suffocation.
(slow guitar music)
Look I think it's the patience.
I fucking did four years everyday
of Wine Library TV before anybody cared.
Nobody watched.
Like I've only really blown
up in the last 2 or 3 years.
After doing it really hard every day,
content of all sorts, wine then business,
for 10 years.
It's just a matter of time.
The only thing that the two
of you need to figure out is,
you know, what, if any, financial needs,
not aspirations,
this is a game of meeting, not hoping,
you know?
Of course we want you
guys, the three of you,
to make a million dollars
a year in advertising
and affiliates and merchandise.
Of course you would
want your, you for sure,
I don't want to impose
what you guys are so young,
you still have to figure out
how much this has to be
or not be or whatever but,
like of course, but,
the only thing you have to think about
when building a business
around your passion,
is what do you need, not
what you're hoping for.
Because if you figure out what you need,
and you can make it happen,
well then you can wait
for what you're hoping for
because you love it.
That's it.
That will take the pressure out of growth,
which will lead you to cry less.
I mean it.
So whether that means you're providing,
whether that means up
front, you guys are like,
no we need another that, we need,
which doesn't you know, and
needing gets real interesting.
There's a lot of people
that are so miserable
who dream about doing a Disney podcast
yet they go to Wegman's
to buy all their food
instead of maybe going to ShopRite.
And in that 89 dollar a week savings,
is their opportunity.
That's how I really believe it.
You know and so like,
there's a lot of things
you guys think are needs that aren't.
And providing for them,
and providing for yourself.
When you're doing this
big of a passion project,
I really think you'll win, I really do.
I believe it.
I just think it takes a lot of time.
And in that three to four years
where you have to give up stuff,
is where people fail.
(upbeat music)